if you haven't already maybe you decided
to write like words sentences which is
fine but if you haven't already please
draw with me a Cartesian plane we're
going to start with this great fact
that's a hand do and Krishan have
provided us so we've got two straight
lines right by the way I'm giving you a
fax for free they've got arrows on the
end of them anyone to give me a reason
why they have arrows go ahead run yeah
they're infinitely big they just go on
forever
unfortunately our pages do not go or
maybe fortunately our pages do not go on
forever but we indicate that the lines
do with the arrows which was which axis
again the wolf x horizontal one y is the
vertical alright so now let's see who we
can go to next all right I'm gonna go a
little back Aryan hideaway taught me
something anything quadrants we have the
word quadrants can you tell us anything
about that
in relation to this specifically what
does that mean
four pieces okay so we have four if you
want the specific word I guess we'd call
them regions spaces on the plane
and we call them quadrants because as
hater correctly said there are four of
them okay
bonus points let's expand and put on our
haters point just like we expand on this
one there are four quadrants which one's
the best one any takers
ma this one here so we coin this one the
first quadrant so which one's the second
one the top leopard it's interesting to
me second quadrant first artists why we
starting yeah
alright so here's another fact I don't
know if you wrote this down but we have
directions here right this is positive
upward and this is also positive to the
right maybe we want to drop that in
positive in this direction and positive
in this direction so positive positive
kind of where we begin right you can go
negative in this direction still
positive you got what's this one
negative and negative and then finally
negative positive um why is it go
anti-clockwise any thoughts on that one
because everything you're like you know
when were you're doing you know you're
reading a clock hence clockwise when
you're in your compass goes clockwise
why does this one go anti-clockwise what
do you recommend you have a theory
just keep going this way yeah now this
is interesting bit of a trick question
we're actually going to learn a lot more
we as in all of us here in the school
maybe not this exact class about why we
decide to go in this opposite direction
to clocks and compasses and all the rest
but in a few years and I just want to
plant that seed that we have this weird
kind of anti clockwise arrangement even
though everything else goes this way all
right someone give me a fact I'm not
going to call that something okay so we
haven't heard the coordinates yet when
you say when we get called it's joy
maybe give us an example and then you
can talk us about 1 4 & 3 ok where
should we put forward 3 which quadrant
did it go in she got the first quadrant
right I'm going to place it about there
4 comma 3 now quick question to you
right we've got two coordinates here
before in the 3/2 ornaments I should say
which one is which which one is the
horizontal one which one's the vertical
one Anoosh what do you think the X
always comes first if you want to go
ahead and with me thank you news if you
want to add on so cornets to your
Cartesian plane they don't have to be
these ones but you do want to make sure
that there's the X first then the Y
second as an additional thing we don't
actually always call them X&Y sometimes
they are different names like remember
we're looking at travel graphs recently
remember what what was the horizontal
axis called for the travel graph it's
called time usually and then this is
like distance or something like that
so rather than why we label that sir
okay
what you put on here okay you can put
straight lines okay so slope is talking
at is this line for example shallow is
it steep I'm gonna say we will explore
that a little bit later on but for now
that's not really effective at the plane
itself we'll leave that one till a bit
later if that's okay now I'm just
checking myself I drew a bunch of things
here to see if I got everything oh
there's a thing missing did anyone talk
about what's on the axes usually anyone
where you got for us - Shaka what would
you call that by the way we say numbers
integers widely integers by the way
there's positive and negative so where
you kind of explained with this positive
maybe for completeness sake we should
also put on the left hand side and on
the bottom that's the negative direction
the Ouiser you gonna add something
[Music]
well you mean what to call the things
that we put on there yeah okay so let's
see why don't we put some things on
there and we might be helpful for us I'm
gonna put in as a marker there yeah
there so let's put some numbers on to
here do we need to put every single
number that exists
hmm now probably when you first met a
Cartesian plane you usually had like
every single number there right or maybe
up to a certain number like 10 as we
start to use these more it's going to
become more and more useful if we just
put the numbers that really matter to us
as an example I'm gonna put three on
here why do you think that might be
important have a look at what I've drawn
on the Cartesian plane Leah what do you
see yeah fantastic this set of
coordinates over here it's not a match
so I can see where it is oh here's
another question the word we were
looking for by the way that tells you
this is its scale how big or small is
this um this is a vertical scale and I
guess if that's three that would make
this link six up here that's the
vertical scale does the horizontal scale
have to be the same does the whole okay
so I'm getting a lot of nods hands up if
you think they should be the same hands
up it's like a third who reckons they
can be different hands up okay it's a
bit of a giveaway of mrs. Lee's purse
her hand up but that's okay now I'm
interested right we got a bit of
disagreement here I think there's
something helpful in both why might it
be useful to keep them both the same
like if that's three I'm gonna make that
three as well why might that be useful
and it sure it might be more clear if
for example I asked you to put in the
corner to say a square right and if I
had one here zero zero maybe one zero
one one
zero-one if I asked you to put the
quarts of a square if that axes don't
match if our scales don't match will it
look like a square a 1 right it'll look
like squashed it might look like a
rectangle that's like flat up however
the people who've won up they head
second are also right why might actually
be more useful to overall say they can
be different like that's a three at the
moment I could make this guy here like
negative 100 if I wanted why am i that
be handy to me what do you think
vishakha who might be the actual
coordinates of a point that might be
valuable I'm think back to the travel
graphs do you guys remember the traps we
even talked about it just now what was
this axis it was time what was this one
those distance which were totally
different units right my ones about
hours or seconds one's about meters or
kilometers okay all right maybe one last
suggestion or thing to put on there
average you have one more thing that's
not on there sorry where you mean if I
put this here
ah now in terms of what has to be the
same if you've got a horizontal scale
you've got to keep on going at the same
amount so see that's yeah they're the
same distance so if that's negative 100
what should that be negative 200 you've
got to keep on going I can't decide
actually I just want that to be negative
a hundred one and should get a little
bit okay